dear diary my mom made me come and check
reindeer on the side of the road today
oh my goodness
you'll see the turn off up here okay
we're gonna pull off and they should be
there
[Music]
is a horse trailer oh look it and one's
on a halt there oh good hopefully
they're gonna be easy to work with
hello hi you guys made it I am so glad
to meet you same here so today we're in
Girdwood and we're meeting up with Hara
who actually drove up from Kenai with
her husband Dan or granddaughter and a
bunch of reindeer this is Abigail hi
Abigail nice to meet you she's holding
crash oh so that's your boy that's your
steer right that's our steer okay
[Music]
we've been raising reindeer for 10 years
our first one was crash
for the last two years has lost a lot of
weight and he is very thin
he eats there's nothing wrong with his
behavior or his appetite he's just not
keeping weight really hoping that Dr
Oakley has something that we can do for
him so he will continue to be with us
he's pretty special
hi crash how are you friend
and you can feel he just he's a little
Ruby why an animal is losing weight is a
huge range of possibilities have you
seen any diarrhea any loose poop at all
parasites cancers a lot of these
metabolic diseases those can all take so
much energy from an animal so that even
if they seem like they're eating
normally they just can't put on any
weight I know I know so I'm just feeling
for lymph nodes trying to feel any kind
of lumps or bumps or anything it's
really important when you're trying to
figure out body condition issues that
you do a physical exam on the animal I
think he likes that
and it's important that you get really
good samples it was about to pee or poop
I was going to make you grab a sample
maybe have a cup ready just in case
getting some samples we can hopefully
try to figure out what's the Smoking Gun
here so I think right off the bat just
to be sure I would love to get a blood
sample okay
all right let's try over here let's see
if crash will cooperate
so we're gonna get a blood sample and
that is going to tell us a little bit
about kidney and liver function over
here good boy it'll tell us overall if
there's any like big chronic infection
going on okay
nobody move I got it oh hold still hold
still almost done crash you're so good
all done buddy
okay so next up we like to get a urine
sample because that'll give us another
look at what's going on internally so
we'll be checking him oh I think he's
gonna is he gonna well maybe
but a urine sample is not one that's
easy to get so oh he's gonna pee he's
gonna pee
sample it's happening and I have no
containers don't go grab it this pea
sample is super important no hey hey
oh no
I just didn't think I reacted I put it
in your pocket and I said I said to have
it handy okay no you put it in your
hands well I was trying I can't believe
she actually did that and it's all over
her hands I probably use my hat before I
would use my hands
high five no absolutely not thank you
sir I want to shake your hand thank you
okay
dang it we'll see if he decides to pee
again while we're here he's got a
grandpa bladder he's gonna he's gonna
pee again in like another 10 minutes so
if we take him in the trailer he'll pee
okay yes
and reindeer are not a species you can
just like you know get to pee on command
can someone make waterfall noisesh
waterfalls Rivers
stage fright I get it we can't put his
little hoof in a bucket of warm water
every time they drink they pee okay I
love it
nothing
doesn't that make you have to pee buddy
that's making me have to pee to that
water noise
we've gone through an intricate pattern
of walking him around in and out of the
stall on the trailer and suddenly the
mood strikes him he's gonna go and this
time I'm ready with the cup
okay nice there it is liquid gold good
boy crash
it is tough with these older guys to
keep weight on so it's really important
that we get these samples set out to get
like an overall picture of what's going
on and then depending on what those
results tell us we can send some
supplements along for her to give it
home
hopefully he puts on some weight and
feels better thank you so much no
problem you guys have a safe trip back
maybe we'll see you down in Kenai
sometime
hopefully he'll be Galloping through the
pasture with the rest of them
[Music]
oh we can barely fit our hips today is
vasectomy day it's a big day for Arnold
today we're at the Alaska Wildlife
Conservation Center we're gonna be
working with Arnold the Moose I need to
give him a vasectomy so that he can be
mixed with the other two females there
without having any babies
he's gonna be living the dream he'll
have two cows and no kids no kids
Arnold is our three-year-old male moose
he's grown up here for the last couple
years he's doing really well but he's
kind of our Miracle moose
his first year with his first set of
antlers he actually broke his antlers so
bad that he cracked his skull plate
right across his forehead
we're just glad that he's still here it
was very risky in the recovery process
but he made it through
hormones like testosterone help regulate
that antler shedding cycle and that's
why vasectomy makes more sense than
castration in this case
well he's he's locked in there
so we're just getting ready to Dart
Arnold I'm a vasectomy is quite
different from a neuter or a castration
it's basically the same as is done in
people and men to avoid having more kids
so we'll just actually be leaving the
testicles intact tying off the tube that
carries the sperm out and he still is
able to breathe no problem but they just
won't have any any moose calves anymore
that was a very long way to say keeps
the balls no babies no babies yeah
that's a hashtag hashtag no babies yes
yes you guys get enough babies that are
orphaned and stuff so it's good to have
room for those guys right exactly
okay
[Music]
so he's locked in okay so I'm just gonna
pop the gate open he's not gonna stop me
no I see I hope not
Arno being a moose he's a thousand
pounds to 1200 pounds easily right now
and he has four gigantic legs that can
kick in any direction
he definitely picks up on my smell he
definitely knows me and um is not
usually thrilled to see me I've really
only got one shot at this
yeah go ahead and we'll pop it open a
little bit
okay oh Arnold Arnold it's okay it's
okay
glad I wasn't in there holy mackerel
sorry buddy and did it inject yes it
dude
yeah that will hopefully get him down
within about five minutes and then we'll
jump in there get them stabilized and
start the surgery
okay serious down
just go slow because it's still early
okay he's kind of laying funny
oh yeah
so Arnold has gone down and not the best
spot in the barn he's kind of right up
in the corner against the fence we're
gonna just go ahead and try to get him
like kind of rolled up on his side we're
gonna rock him a bit because he's kind
of bloated
that's good just see how this bloat
situation is is he pulling up really bad
already
so Arnold is already getting a little
bit bloaty sometimes depending on what
they've eaten that day you know if he's
been eating a lot of brows or a lot of
grass because he's not burping normally
his body is just making gas
and today is a real gassy day
and if he's not able to burp he's gonna
just keep getting bloatier and bloatier
I'm definitely in his room and
I have to go with the tube down the
esophagus and actually into the first
part of his stomach the rumen and that's
where I'll get all the gas coming back
out it's barely coming out of here it's
very important that we help him relieve
that gas because otherwise the pressure
of that will make it hard to inflate his
lungs and make it hard for blood to flow
so he can go into shock just from
something as simple as bloat
foreign
I'm not sure I would put my mouth on
that it's like legit chunkies in there
I am getting a little bit of gas back
but it's just not quite enough
I've tried to blow some of the stomach
material blocking it
but it's not really helping
our flip sakes
you know bloat is a really serious
condition and we need Arnold to burp
[Music]
yes nice
so it's getting a little bit of the gas
out okey-dokey but what we need to do is
just get started on the surgery so we
can get him on his feet and get him
burping on his own all right
let the fun begin
I'm not actually removing the testicles
in this procedure we want the hormones
there so that he normally sheds his
antlers and grows them every year I'm
removing the tube that takes the sperm
out of the penis so Arnold will still be
able to make sperm normally I'm just
cutting out the exit root so he won't
make any babies the title of this
procedure is have your cake and eat it
too
yeah do you see that that's the tube I'm
trying to get at see that that's the vas
deference that's the tube for the
swimmers snap
there so there's a little bit of as
deference we don't want swimmers one
fish that's all it takes okay I'm gonna
start on the other one all right all
right
so now I'm on the second one where is
this thing there's the testicle so it's
got to be coming off right there can you
just hold this drape up for now but as
I'm making my cut it's coming out of its
little
out
the testicle pops out
once I get it
the testicle sits inside this like kind
of tight little tunic and it kind of
keeps everything contained
that thing just pops right out it's like
opening a can of those snakes like the
joke snakes
hopefully or may not go back in we'll
see
and now I know I'm in trouble
I'm not sure if I might have to remove
this testicle and see once the testicle
is out of its tunic it is not easy to
get it back in
sure you're thinking you might have to
just castrate that
I'm gonna see if I can tuck it back in
there
oh I feel it I think
like here oh my God you guys
we're fighting against the clock here
the testicle is out he's bloating like
crazy I really have to either get this
thing back in a tuna quickly or just
call it and remove it
yeah I'm just gonna remove it it's
getting angry and swollen and everything
ah what a fail that makes me mad
this is more of a pride thing I wanted
to do a really nice vasectomy you know
get both sides tied off he's got one he
only needs one testicle to have enough
testosterone to grow antlers shed
antlers and even to breed okay so let me
just need to strip it and castrate It
Forward masculating yeah I'm gonna
remove this one sorry Arnold a lot of
times when you're in surgery it's not
going exactly according to the textbook
and you just have to kind of pivot and
go with it and finish off that job oh
your big bloaty belly
oh yeah let's get him sternal
okay mister how are you okay I'm gonna
give him the reversal guys he's too
bloated away good boy
that smells good if you haven't smelled
room and burp it's really rain
oh my goodness buddy but because he was
starting to have some bloaty issues it
was a huge side relief for all of us
involved yeah you let those burps out
oop everybody out
go ahead Jimmy
okay but okay Sarah look out
it's always this balance between what's
the ideal thing you can do and you know
what's your situation
in fact this whole procedure was like
that I know bud
so my pride might be wounded but Arnold
is not he's gonna be fine No One's Gonna
want me to do a human vasectomy ever
fifty percent off
okay poor buddy Arnold's gonna be
released with the lady soon he can strut
his stuff and he'll still be all bull
moose
[Music]
he ran out in the road I hope he's okay
he was coughing up some blood
it's okay
hi hello
these are brothers he ran out in the
road and got hit by a car okay he took a
tumble um he had some blood coming out
of his mouth yeah I see that and I
wasn't sure it looked like he was
coughing it up and then he's got a
pretty deep cut right here
Dr Oakley will be here shortly okay we
have two six-month-old Doberman puppies
they're boys they're from the same
litter and Ruger he's my bullish
Troublemaker kind of led the charge and
went straight up the road and a car
hit him how long ago did this happen uh
25 minutes
I didn't see it happen but I heard him
scream and I knew that is my dog under
someone's car
and it was really scary
we just got an emergency call on our day
off so we rushed the clinic as fast as
we can
as soon as I see Ruger though I can see
immediately he sent a State of Shock
come here comes money
no as I pull up I see that Ruger looks
very lethargic his pupils are huge he's
scared got hit by a car I heard him
scream right away yep as I pull up his
lip and look at his mucous membranes
they're pale and he's definitely shocky
pale mucous membranes can mean there's
been a lot of internal bleeding okay so
we're going to take him in see what his
vitals are like get him stabilized and
I'll be right out to let you know how
it's okay thank you I'm really worried
like we need to get him in immediately
and start getting him checked out and
stabilized get some vitals on him give
him oxygen
oh this is such a nightmare
I'm still in shock
these boys are these are our children
our other children
is Ruby okay is Ruby okay yeah he's okay
I've gotten to know Gabe and Tracy
through their previous dog Apollo
good boy one of the sweetest Dobermans
I've ever met he had dilated
cardiomyopathy a common heart condition
in Dobermans and unfortunately he passed
of it last year
that was very hard I know for them and
their family and I can only imagine what
they're all thinking right now
[Music]
we went through so much this past year
after losing Apollo so to have this
incident happen it's just terrifying
we cannot go through losing another dog
this year I can't
that's interesting
for a hit by car of course the first
thing we're looking for is shock and
that could be because of pen trauma that
could because of internal bleeding so
right now Sierra's getting my IV hints
because if we have to medicate for any
of those issues especially IV fluids to
help blood pressure that's tanking we
want the IV in there
any kind of trauma to the abdomen can
cause really fast and life-threatening
internal bleeding that needs surgery
immediately
and I look in your mouth
look at that
man that's a grown-up broken tooth right
down here poo poo
seeing that he's cracked a canine does
explain why there could be a lot of
blood in his mouth but I don't know that
that's the only cause for blood in his
mouth
what I want to do is now look in his
belly and make sure I don't see any
signs of bleeding because that would
mean go into surgery
ah
he's doing a quick abdominal scan I'm
trying to see if there's any type of
internal bleeding going on
it's hard when you get into a
hemoabdomen like a belly that's full of
blood to find the source of that
bleeding and try to stop it fast enough
what I can see so far liver looks good
spleen looks good I don't see a lot of
abdominal fluid which is awesome
okay we're gonna get some x-rays buddy
so the next thing I want to do quickly
is check out his chest you're such a
good boy
yes sir okay hit the light
when you have that type of trauma of
course even the lung tissue can bleed
that Blood starts to collect in that
area just get a good chest film so I am
still concerned about damage to the
lungs puncture to a lung
[Applause]
it does look like he has some fluid in
his lungs maybe looking at the x-rays
I'm not surprised to see that there's a
little bit of patchy thickness to his
lung field where it should just look
more like black and clear just this area
here that kind of
separated a fluid that's likely either a
little bit of bleeding or a little bit
of like almost like inflammation in his
lung tissue I think maybe he has a
little bit of a pneumothorax there's a
little line
can you pull this arm forward for me
when he got hit that big slam to his
lungs probably forced air out of the
lung but inside his chest cavity so now
there's a little bit of air leaking
outside of his lung
his stats are good but this looks really
mild and a lot of these pneumothoraxes
will just resolve on their own hey good
boy stay I think we're gonna try one in
his mouth because he's being so good so
we're also doing some dental X-rays
where he cracked that canine so we'll
get this one
foreign
that is the whole giant root is there
you can see where it's actually just
like fractured off that is going to be
really hard to get out but it has to
come out
we're gonna schedule that once he's had
a few days to recover before we bring
him back in to put them under anesthesia
to remove the tooth so far compared to
everything else that could have happened
I'll take it all right I'll check out
that leg let's put him left leg down so
I can look at that we'll clean it up a
bit
he has a laceration underneath his elbow
um it's it's pretty deep down deep I'm
gonna open that up a bit to flush it
so this is a dirty wound because there's
a gravel drug in there so we're gonna
flush I'm gonna need a pile of flush
once I get it nice and clean I'll
freshen the edges and close it up
okay
okay we gotta do this and still make
prom kids
Today Is Willows uh junior prom she's a
junior today's her prom and
um we have to get over there so we can
see her and Eric all dressed up then
ready to go it wouldn't be the first
time I showed up for like family photos
or parent-teacher interviews or prom
photos with blood on my hands you know
it's just you showed up in your full
base and get up via helicopter to my
apparent teacher and everything
I made it though didn't I you did make
it see I mean two-thirds of parenting is
showing up so I was there I just looked
a little ragged
okay so Mr man we're done
a big relief
we're going to send them home with pain
meds in a few days we're going to get
him back in when he's a bit more stable
and feeling better and remove the rest
of that very painful canine root
I hope you learned a lesson
you've got to look both ways and better
yet don't even go out there
I'm so glad for Ruger that everything
was fairly simple and straightforward
it feels heavier than it used to it
could have been a lot worse
oh he's coming he's coming
there it is there's your baby boy oh all
right let's get him right in the truck
there we go
whoa ready to get home oh my goodness
I'm so relieved I'm so relieved thank
you he took it down
he's it's not super serious when he gets
home he gets to be in Mommy and Daddy's
bed for quite a while he's gonna get a
lot of snuggles
yes it was supposed to be my day off but
I'm just so glad I was here that I could
get in and help Ruger and there's still
time for us all to go up and see Willow
after prom
okay wait I need to get pictures hang on
that dress is gorgeous and those Roses
who paid for those
[Music]
off into the sunset
[Music]
come on good boy
come here
hello hello how are you Kelsey good well
hello
[Music]
let's hear what's been going on ear
infection right yes Gus has had a
chronic ear infection since about the
end of April oh man Gus is my
five-year-old Shih Tzu a couple years
ago he was actually hit by a car out in
front of our house the person drove off
kind of left him there and ever since
then he's had issues with ear infections
he has been suffering with a chronic ear
infection for about three months now
he's been on antibiotics twice and it
just has not resolved his ears are just
still super sensitive and nasty Brown
yeah goopy stuff coming out when ear
infections last longer they can cause
more damage but more importantly the
pain and the suffering of a chronic ear
infection I mean that's what we really
need to deal with here and clear up
is he otherwise okay up to date in his
vaccines and everything else good
awesome okie dokie we'll bring him right
back out in a few minutes and check with
you okay thanks all right
I
I'm nervous this is very important
member of my family
my grade the sphere is that we will
discover that he has a major issue uh
ruptured eardrum so
just keeping my fingers crossed that
it's something simple okay let's do a
quick physical hello hello guys
let me have a look ooh yeah
there's like a big chunk of wax right
there that black
what I can see is a lot of really black
Caked Up yucky earwax okay let me look
this side
oh my love
oh gosh that looks gnarly
that ear is red hot really tender I
really feel bad I mean anyone that's
ever had an ear infection you know
that's incredibly painful
let us actually look and flush he's
probably gonna need a muzzle too because
it's so uncomfortable I want to have a
look with the otoscope and I want to be
sure that there's not a foreign body in
there should we put a little muzzle on
his short face Maya
you ready I wouldn't blame him for
biting because it's so uncomfortable
hopefully that distracts him a little
bit from what we're doing with his ear
and very steady his head there
he's a Wiggler
hey Sierra yes we're gonna need extra
set of hands
okay get in there
I guess
oh
my goodness I want to hurt your eye
buddy
I can't see anything
all the gunk in Gus's ear it's just
really tough to see through that I think
we're going to just flush it with saline
and I'm hoping if I can get enough of
that debris out of the way I can get a
better look down into the canal and see
what's causing the problem we're just
gonna lose
come on
getting bit by a gas didn't feel great
but it definitely could have been worse
I think we better reschedule him for a
sedation in your flush and we're just
gonna put him on oral antibiotics for a
couple days first it's too painful it's
too much buddy to put YouTube
it's much better if we just sedate him
we'll have him back and get him in early
and then do a proper job where I can
actually get in there have a really good
look and hopefully fix whatever's going
on come on guys let's go home
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you ready for Ebenezer Scrooge yeah I'm
all set up all the stuff set up back
there that's nice so today we're at the
Alaska Wildlife Conservation Center and
my patient that's coming in is a little
unusual Sarah says she's grabbing Mr
Scrooge okay you know when you think of
Alaska and Wildlife you think moose
Bears bison
hi hello but I don't know if you think
about red squirrels
friend Ebenezer Scrooge he's our rescued
squirrel from chickaloon Alaska area
the gentleman that rescued him tried to
release him and ebb kept coming back and
so that typically means that he's too
habituated to survive on his own so we
all work together to give him a
permanent placement here at the Wildlife
Center
but he needs to be neutered
he's he's definitely a red squirrel come
at me bro
hopefully it'll kind of get rid of some
of the territorial behavioral issues
that we're seeing with him
try this Sierra's got gloves she's going
to try and pin him in the pillowcase or
just make sure
squirrels bite hard he can bite through
these gloves if he really wanted to and
through this pillowcase easy so I've
decided to use a pillowcase kind of over
the Trap run them into it and then
you've got them there and then that way
their kind of heads contain their bodies
contain they can't start scratching and
getting away
eating
right oh God he's scared
okay you got him you got him okay
wait that's his butt for sure okay you
can actually inject right through the
pillowcase into their muscle
sorry friend
so now we just let him be quiet
[Music]
did you dream about going to the nut
Factory the nut Factory
Dr Oakley and I have worked together so
long I'm fully expecting to hear tons of
squirrel nut jokes
so the planning seems to have paid off
he is out yeah
the ever cute whoa you know what I'm
saying why what big testicles you have
the better to impregnate you with wow
yeah those are that's a set I mean that
literally is the purpose you know they
need to store a lot of sperm they need
to rip around and impregnate as many
females as possible they are a large
Marge and you pass on your genetics
right
time for some squirrel biz
those are the two large testicles
they're kind of like cashew shaped okay
I'm too mature to be a part of this
all right
cutting
I'm castrated neutered a lot of things
and he's one of the tinier things I've
worked on
the principles are the same
so there is testicle number one it's
pretty good size
all right sir we can remove your nuts
from you
and get you on your way
yeah look at that
just like a little cashew
did you feel how like heavy these are
well they're like they actually have
some weight though what are you talking
about these the nuts they have like
weight to them
yeah I know these are so aren't they why
are they so hot whatever
ah
Nose No Cap shoes don't worry
[Laughter]
Ebenezer is doing fine okay he is ready
okay okay he's gonna recover quickly and
not even know what he's missing what's a
squirrel without his nuts a much Kinder
gentler squirrel
foreign
[Music]
there he is so I've got Gus here in the
clinic today she's been dealing with the
ear infection for about three months
his ears were so uncomfortable and and
painful it was really hard to look at
them properly we're going to go ahead
and sedate him so I can get a much
better look in his ears oh oh my
we're going to try and go right into the
main line for this buddy
so he should be getting sleepy is he
getting Sleepy's here yes
his ears are really gunky so it's hard
to know what they're like until I sort
of get some things out of the way
when you have a lot of pressure behind
the ear or you have a chronic infection
either of those things can rupture the
eardrum so I really need to make sure
that the eardrum is still present I
look
once you have a ruptured eardrum you
could get a septic infection it can
affect their balance and can definitely
affect their hearing well I can see an
eardrum okay buddy hold on so looking in
the right ear canal he's got a very nice
looking eardrum all righty then other
side
this here is a lot more painful
yeah that one's like full and it looks
really red and painful oh they smell as
I'm moving over to the left ear canal
it's funky I can smell it it's just so
wet and gooey in there
I see like black debris pus and like so
much gnarly hair oh
some dogs are prone to ear infections
there's a lot of heat being kept in
there and wetness and and that can
develop a yeast infection and then it
becomes a bacterial infection that can
be a lot more serious and painful
look there's a big chunk
okay let me look
oh no
I should see an eardrum and all I see is
like a black hole there oh there's blood
Gus's eardrum has definitely ruptured so
he has a very severe middle ear and
probably inner ear infection yeah I mean
if you could see what I'm seeing right
now it's brutal everything around it is
just like massively swollen and like
sloughing
a ruptured eardrum will tend to close up
on its own and heal over it can take
months to do that but the most important
thing now is that we just treat the
infection that's going on yay let me get
some flush
so I'm not going to put anything in this
eardrum besides saline the flush is
really getting most of it out which is
nice we're going to put them on some
heavy duty antibiotics and a lot of pain
meds yes my Lobby and give time for that
eardrum to heal okay
I know
sweet
we're gonna send Gus home now with
Kelsey just to watch him and make sure
he gets his medications regularly
so he did awesome he did great there is
good news bad news one of his eardrums
is totally normal the other one is in
fact ruptured okay so we do have some
medication that we're going to be
sending you back with to help heal that
okay poor guy look at that smile look at
your smile
I am super relieved to have Gus back at
least I know what's going on we have the
medications now to help treat that and
just gonna keep our fingers crossed that
things will heal on its own I have him
back he's doing good so we're happy
laughs
[Music]
so we've got some results back on Crash
the reindeer
he was struggling earlier this summer
with a lot of body condition issues he
was losing muscling he had lost a lot of
weight he's a little Ruby now that we've
got the urine blood results back we can
feel pretty confident that crash is
doing well he's not losing any protein
in his urine his kidneys liver you know
white blood cell counts those are all
normal no indications of cancer or any
kind of like big smoking guns you did
have a pretty good parasite load so that
is a lot of calories that are going to
feed friends that don't need to be there
so we dewormed him to make sure he's not
sharing any of those groceries with any
parasites and also gave him some B
vitamins and other supplemental feed
additives and he has responded
wonderfully
Here Comes crash
he's put on weight he's putting on
muscle he's running around and seeming
much better
he is moving so much better
[Music]
oh my gosh he looks great yeah so we saw
Ruger not too long ago when he was hit
by a car
and now he's back and he looks like a
completely different dog so how was he
how's he doing he's not limping or
anything I think two days after he
seemed like it was normal yeah but yeah
puppies bounced back that's a good thing
but we still have that tooth to deal
with right yeah yeah so I can take him
from you all right here bud see you
later buddy okay hold on you're fine
so River got hit by a car a week and a
half ago he definitely had some bruising
some serious contusions in his chest and
his abdomen but mostly he did okay
except for a very large fractured canine
it's an adult canine unfortunately and
it absolutely has to be removed because
all the blood vessels and all the nerves
are totally exposed and if you leave it
in there that would just form a huge
abscess alrighty I have to give him a
little pinch in his booty
oh God those are like thunder thighs
dude it's a big procedure very painful
so this is going to require general
anesthesia
look at his sad face
of the canine goes actually back along
in the Jawbone there's a lot to it it's
not just cutting you know straight down
it's actually making a flap and going
underneath other teeth to get at the
root of it
okay so what I'm doing now is just
getting this kind of flap so we can get
the tissue away and start taking away
the bone that's kind of holding it
so I'm just going down
one of the worst things I could find is
I go in and open up the gum to remove
the tooth is that it's starting to like
chip and Fracture away into bits that is
a young growing tooth so that outer
layer is kind of like eggshell and it'll
easily Splinter and just break off and
that makes it really tricky to remove
everything and you can't leave even a
little bit behind or it could cause an
abscess
okay
oh God I'm trying to peel that skin and
tissue off of the bone
I wonder if that's fractured oh it is
totally
it's a bloody thing
as I'm getting the gum flat back I can
see ruger's tooth is fractured yep the
outside of the tooth is cracked and all
we're looking at is Pulp so when you
look in here it's like the tooth part is
missing from there and that's just like
soft the inside of the tooth is what's
left yeah right there
in addition to pain open pulp Chambers
it can open up areas for infection so
animals can get infected tartar areas
but that can get up under the gum they
can get right into the base of the jaw
and cause very serious infections even
infections internally and I can't leave
any bits behind because those could
cause an abscess later
which is peeled away
that is the meaty pulp of the tooth and
you can see the outside of the tooth is
around it like the actual like shell of
the tooth is right there
so now I'm getting down around the edge
of the like outside enamel of the tooth
and I'm loosening it from the bone
okay there we go and out it's coming
oh my gosh is it the tooth yep amazingly
this tooth has come out all in one piece
so that's very lucky yay it's all done
that is what came out quite a bit and
that was all below the gum line that
looks painful that's all nerves and
vessels and tissue and that was like
totally exposed really glad that we got
that done for him because that was super
painful
that was a lot faster than expected and
now I'm just going to close up the gum
put some sutures across there and he'll
be good to go
[Music]
luckily the mouth heals fast he'll be
definitely really sore for a week or two
but he's gonna feel so much better I
mean that hurt more than anything so
Ruger will be just fine with the missing
canine he has three others he doesn't
need that tooth to be a healthy dog that
really looks good you could barely ever
tell there was ever a tooth there yeah
that's Incredible the Incredible Dr
Oakley the incredible doctor
these sutures are dissolvable so there's
no like removing sutures they'll be gone
in a few weeks here we go
so now we're going to go ahead and wake
them up
done like dinner
it's great to send them home and know
that he's going to be completely better
right oh there he is he's ready to go
yay he's so happy to see you guys hi
Ruger come inside
there you go oh look at you
he's he did great for his surgery wear
him with that tooth from his bottom jaw
there's kind of a big like Dent there a
little bit of a defect and some stitches
he'll absorb those stitches and that
will fill in in like three or four weeks
so it won't be a big divot there so what
you guys need to do is make sure he
doesn't run around too much for the next
couple days and then can you guys make
sure he has soft food so it's easier for
him to chew it and you'll see there's
kind of a dent where you know there was
some bone removed but that's just going
to fill in and he still has three nice
pearly white canines there right and all
the rest of his teeth he's chewing on
the couch
we love this dog we went through so much
this past year after losing our other
Dobby
these boys have been our Our Hope these
dogs are attached at the hip to my
children we've had them for only a few
short months I wish we could bubble wrap
them
I'm really glad that he's he's okay he's
already just fine oh good boy and you
guys make sure you give them lots of
loves and pets okay oh good job
Ruger is a lucky boy I mean 10 days ago
we feared the worst
he's lucky to be alive he's lucky that
his injuries weren't more serious and
you know he's he's really lucky that
this tooth came out nicely he's gonna
heal up just fine and be a happy healthy
dog soon
[Music]
and any typical that practice it can be
such a huge range of what we need to do
no day is ever the same you have to be
preparing for everything
sometimes the plans work boy there you
go there we go come on but other times
we don't have a cup handy quick go grab
it go grab it sometimes you just got
oh no that's my advice for Life catch
that pee ninja pea catching so there it
is liquid gold
it always feels good when you figure
things out and get the job done
and the goal is help the animal
Go With It Roll With It wash your hands
after unwashable
[Music]
[Music]